we want and welcome to today's webinar
the essential role of motto RNA and mRNA
on cancer progression and biomarker
discovery presented by dr. Martha the
cones had a basic research connect for
gastroenterology University of Marburg
my name is Vidya Venkatesh I'm from
thermo Fisher Scientific and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring to you this education
of not presented by lab booths sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this is an interactive event we'd
like you to ask as many questions as you
like during the presentation as well
just click on the green Q&A button
located on the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question and box that appears on the
screen we will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end and we'll
get back to you suppose that we didn't
get there during the live event please
note that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window or
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or sharing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
the presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits I'd now like to
introduce our presenter dr. Walter
workers obtained his PhD in molecular
biology from the University of cotton in
Germany in 1998 his guild leader and
head of basic research at the Department
of gastroenterology endocrinology and
metabolism the University of Marburg
Hospital I work for more information
about our speaker please do click on his
picture at the top left corner without
further ado I hand it over to dr. Martha
because take us through the informative
presentation thank you video for the
kind
invitation to present some of our data
here and I'm happy to do that and I'd
like to start off with just a couple of
seconds explaining where we're coming
from as the title of this talk already
hints that we are working on pancreatic
cancer and pancreatic cancer if you are
hearing talks about it
they are often started with the sentence
that pancreatic cancer really has the
worst prognosis among all cell the
tumors so what does that mean in
practical terms
so this slide that I borrowed from the
American Cancer Society shows a couple
of numbers about survival rates of
different tumors so the percentages of
patients that are still alive five years
after they first got their cancer
diagnosis and if you look at the lower
right you'll see that for example
prostate cancer has a very good
prognosis almost 100% of patients are
still alive five years after diagnosis
and right next to it breast cancer has
improved tremendously over the last
years and decades and almost 90 percent
of the patients are still alive five
years after their diagnosis but if you
now look for pancreatic cancer all the
way up here on the left you will see
that the number is only 5% and in
reality it's actually even lower so less
than 5% of patients will still be alive
five years after they first were
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer and
there's a couple of reasons for this
dismal prognosis and chief among them is
the fact that the tumor is extreme
extremely resistant against chemotherapy
and radiotherapy and the only hope for
cure actually that we can offer to the
patients is the resection the complete
resection of the tumor at an early stage
but this is complicated very often by
the fact that we usually catch the tumor
too late so by the time that the
diagnosis is final and is fixed only
between five and twenty percent of the
patients are really amenable for
surgical resection with the intent of
curing the patient all others can only
be treated palliative lis
so the complete removal of the tumor
which surgeons called the r0 resection
is actually the only hope for cure that
we have at the moment but for this the
timely and accurate diagnosis of the
tumor it really is crucial and what is
usually done in the diagnostic workup of
patients who are suspected of having a
malignant tumor in the pancreas is that
a fine needle is advanced into the tumor
and some material is aspirated from this
mass and then it's expelled onto a
microscope slide and then a pathologist
tries to determine if there is evidence
of malignant cells present in this
cytology and this works reasonably well
when there is cells malignant cells
present in the Esprit but very often
also the diagnosis cannot be made
because the sample is non diagnostic and
in very experienced centers the accuracy
of diagnosis of this procedure is around
80% so our idea many years ago already
was to improve this situation by
including other forms of diagnosis so
recover residual material and the way
molecular analysis of this material to
get to a better and faster diagnosis and
what we did a couple years ago was to
create specialized SI DNA arrays and for
that we took our own data but also gene
expression data from other sources from
stage libraries from literature from
other bio banks or gene banks and we
assembled a set of a total of 588
features or genes that we assembled on
these cDNA arrays and then we tested if
these arrays could give us diagnostic
information if we use it to analyze
finding the aspiration material from
patients and the case that we studied
the differential diagnosis that we
looked at first it was the
differentiation
malignant tumors which is called PDAC
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma and on
the other hand an inflammatory tumor in
the pancreas it's called chronic
pancreatitis which across needs to be
treated completely differently and this
turned out to work very well so we
analyzed a total of 62 tissue samples
and divided this in the training set and
the test set we program we produce these
gene expression profiles from these
samples we look for principal components
in these data and constructed from that
a classifier and then we tested this
classifier on the test set of 20 samples
that had not been used to train the
classifier and we saw that we got a very
good diagnostic accuracy of 95 percent
out of this and it is represented by
this little schematic on the right side
of this slide so this was encouraging
and it showed us that in gene expression
analysis from minute amounts of biopsy
material from pancreatic tumors can
really aid in the diagnostic decision
distinguishing between inflammatory
tumors and malignant cancer but the
situation was not ideal in our view
because this system that we used the
seed in the arrays is a very
experimental system it used radioactive
labeling of the samples very long
exposure times to get the information
for each individual patient samples so
we were looking for a system where we
could use the same principle but on a
better technological basis and we found
it in the tech man array system
microfluidic cards and for those of you
who may not be familiar with tech man
arrays
this is a schematic representation of
what these arrays look like
so this here is one segment of a card
and this here is a larger representation
of what this card looks like and as you
can see it has all these little blue
reaction chambers within the card and
every reaction chamber is served by one
of these loading ports here so pipe
hitting a sample into one of these
loading ports will serve 48 different
reaction chambers and in each of these
reaction chambers one tech man array
will be pre deposited so that a
real-time PCR reaction will take place
at this point for one specific gene and
what we thought would be advantages of
this system was we had a selected set of
genes from our previous analyses real
time PCR offers a much greater dynamic
range than radioactive labeling of
samples most sensitive detection of
course fast analysis no five-day
exposure times and much easier handling
because most of the components of
reactions are already deposited in the
slide and we only have to add the
samples next aspect that we wanted to
also include while we improved our
diagnostic system was that we wanted to
also include the analysis not only of
mRNA Marcus but also micro RNAs and the
reason behind this was that it has been
known by the time already that micro
RNAs are important players in regulation
of gene expression that they are often
miss regulated in pancreatic cancer
along with their target mRNAs and that
they are because they are so small very
stable in all kinds of analytical
material so potentially very good marker
molecules as well so we thought that
simultaneous detection of mRNA and micro
RNA would be highly desirable and we
started working together very closely
with the folks at applied by assistance
which
now part of thermo Fisher and we try to
implement it in one single tech manere
cart microfluidic cart and this is what
the initial version of such a mixer ray
looked at like in our hands so we
selected 79 of our mRNA genes from our
previous analyses along with six mRNA
reference genes that we used - as a
reference for normalizing the data the
mRNA data separately from the micro RNA
data and we selected nine micro RNA
genes and that had been described in the
literature of being differentially
expressed between pancreatic cancer and
chronic pancreatitis and we included two
small RNA reference genes for a
normalization of the micro rnas and
together this was a set of 96 genes and
as you can see here this was represented
on to loading ports or served by two
loading ports in one of these
microfluidic cards so that each sample
was loaded in the two of those loading
port and which means that in on each of
these take memory cards we could analyze
four different samples for different
patient samples and the protocol that we
used for the analyses of these samples
back then was slightly different than
what we're using today we S or we
aspirate the tumor material as I showed
you a couple of slides earlier did a
total RNA extraction mRNA and micro RNA
simultaneously from these samples cDNA
was prepared from these samples using
custom gene specific
primer pools for the mRNAs and the micro
RNAs and then we used the tech male
micro RNA reverse transcription kid to
produce seeding a from that preamplifier
the whole mix all this was done in one
tube preamplifier the whole makes you
using custom gene-specific primer pool
and limited cycling and then loaded
these mixed samples onto the segment
arrays and we need a couple of analyses
first to ensure that this gave us
reprobate afore both the mRNA and micro
RNA genes and I'm not going to go into
too much detail on the analysis that we
did but we produced RNA pools from
pancreatic cancer cell lines for this
purpose we worked up these RNA pools on
different days with different replicates
to make sure that we could compare how
reproducible this procedure was from a
purely technical standpoint and the
results were very good as you can see
here on this heat map where we charted a
gene expression value which is encoded
as green for low expression red for high
expression and gray for missing value
you can see that the technical
replicates very cluster most closely
together as shown here and if you look
at the same samples on two different
days this is the next level of
replicability here and you see that
they're very very similar and if we have
the RNA pools once unamplified and once
pre amplified then these again cluster
very closely together if we compare this
to material from primary tumors here on
the right hand side which are clearly
and separate from the RNA pool
replicates so high level of references
ability and appropriate detection and
pre amplification of both mRNAs and
micro rna's so that was very encouraging
and we went on to analyze a series a
large series of prospectively collected
finally aspiration biopsy samples
these were from all kinds of suspect
masses in the pancreas and they included
a number of 41 ductal adenocarcinoma x'
and 33 of these cases where there was
just a chronic inflammation present in
the pancreas but not a malignant tumor
and this was the distinction that we
concentrated on first and the first
question that we asked was how well will
micro RNA markers the nine micro RNA
markets that we included specifically
because they were described in the
literature to be good discriminators of
malignant tumors and inflammatory tumors
in the pancreas how well would they
perform in trying to distinguish between
these samples and to get a very good and
conservative estimate of this we
employed a method that is called 10 by
10 fold cross validation I'm not going
to go into too much detail of this and
just the basic principle is if you look
at the whole data set which is
symbolized symbolized here by this bar
and if you imagine that these red
samples are the tumor samples and and
the green assembles are the chronic
pancreatitis samples or the proportional
samples that are really chronic chronic
pancreatitis then this is divided into
ten equal sets which is which you can
see below in the next step and then a
classifier is trained with nine of these
subsets and then tested on the tenth
this is what's symbolized here and then
in the next step the whole thing is
repeated just that a different set of
samples is left out of the training and
then tested on later and all the way
until all three all ten I'm sorry all
ten subsets have once been left out of
the training and have been tested on and
all the while is always counted how many
of the diagnostic calls have been
correct or has been false and from that
a diagnostic accuracy is calculated and
if you do
this with just the mind micro or any
markers that we selected then the best
performing classifier we tested all
possible combinations of micro rna's
within this set and the best performing
classifier reached an accuracy of 75%
this is symbolized here by the circle on
the left side which is not better but of
course by far not good enough to really
do Diagnostics so next we looked at the
performance when we take micro RNA
markers as well as mRNA markers and this
is again the whole set of samples mRNA
markers and micro RNA markers for the
distinction between chronic pancreatitis
this is given here as CP and the
malignant samples that is given here is
PDA C and it's already a very simple
analysis every rakah code cluster
analysis as symbolized here by the heat
map on the left side shows you that the
distinction was relatively good even
with simple analyses so you can readily
see blocks of chronic pancreatitis
samples and they are separate from the
blocks of ductal adenocarcinoma samples
so for a set of 88 different markers
it's not possible to exhaustively test
all possible combinations but what we
did was we selected or we did an
analysis where we ranked all individual
genes mRNA and micro RNA genes for the
individual ability to distinguish
between PDAC and CP samples and then we
assembled more markers to build
classifiers starting with the best
individual performing classifier first
and then we tested in using the same
procedure the 10 by 10 fold cross
validation that I showed you earlier how
well
these combinations of markers performed
in the distinction between chronic
pancreatitis and ductal adenocarcinoma
and what turned out was led a collection
of 77 micro RNA and mRNA markers in the
mixed combination had the absolute best
performance in the ten by ten full
cross-validation which is very rigorous
and it reached an accuracy of 93 percent
for the distinction between these
samples and this was accompanied by a
sensitivity of 91.7 in the specificity
of 94.5% and what you see here on the
right side of this chart is that if you
train the classifier with all samples
and then retest on all samples you get
100% distinction between the two classes
so very high diagnostic accuracy and
shows clearly that the simultaneous
analysis of Micra or any and mRNA is
superior to just looking at micro rna's
alone so this is about to be published
it's impress in Ankur target and you can
read about this in more detail in a
couple of days when the paper is online
but still this was not the end for us we
still have more plans because the
analysis of fine needle aspiration
biopsy is still a very invasive
procedure so a needle has to be inserted
deep into the abdomen of the patients to
get the aspiration biopsy samples and
ideally we would like to be able to do
Diagnostics non-invasively which means
using blood as an analytical sample and
this is where we are currently this
ongoing research we have
produced another version of a mixed
Tecna array for this purpose
specifically we selected from our set of
mRNA candidates where we know that they
are helpful in a distinction between
doctor adeno carcinoma chronic
pancreatitis we selected from them a set
of mRNA genes that we can regularly see
in the serum of patients as well and
these are mended with six mRNA reference
genes and we did de novo a whole neural
analysis of markers micro RNA markers
that are present in the serum of doctor
Ladino carcinoma patients and we
selected from those a set of 37
potentially diagnostic micro RNA markers
along with 5 micro RNA reference genes
so if you do the math you'll see that
together this is again a 96 gene panel
which takes up 2 loading ports on a tech
manere card so again we can analyze for
patient samples on one of these mixed
Ekman array cards and the specific idea
that we're using this version of a
non-invasive diagnostic potentially
diagnostic technology for now is to
detect recurrence of pancreatic cancer
and to detect it earlier then we can
detect recurring tumor with the message
that we have at the moment and the
protocol that we use for analysis of
diagnostic samples is slightly different
now than what I've shown you before
because there is a new generation of
tech menaces for micro rna's out now
that are called tech men advanced essays
and the principle here if you
concentrate on the right side of the
schematic is that the micro RNAs are
amended by a poly a tail in reaction and
allegation of a five-prime adaptor so
that you end up we
a universal or with the possibility to
use a set of universal primers to
amplify all the microRNAs that are
present in one sample and again in the
same tube we do the reverse
transcription of the MRNA markers using
standard random hexamer protocols and
amplify those then genes specifically
with primers that are specific to each
of the 49 marker genes that we have all
this happens together in one tube and
then we can load those assembles again
onto the tech manere cards and get the
quantification of all the markers
simultaneously and the reason that we're
looking for tumor recurrence is that
it's been clearly shown that patients
who suffer from relapse do much better
if the relapsing tumor is called early
on and then it can either be operated
again or treated with chemotherapy so we
have found a V consortium within Europe
with partners from Germany Italy and
from Madrid in Spain and what we're
doing within this project is following
up patients who had undergone r0 of a
section of a pancreatic tumor and
collecting serum samples during the
follow-up follow-up of these patients
and archiving the serum samples until
the time point when there's the
clinically overt diagnosis of tumor
recurrence and then we split up the
samples into samples that can go into
the no evidence of disease groups so at
least 12 months after a sample like this
has been collected there was no tumor
recurrence and on the other hand the
samples were a recurring tumor was
already clearly present and we will use
the tecnine array cards to determine if
our selection of markers can clearly
distinguish between these two types of
samples from the same patient
of course we are in the process of
collecting these samples so we don't
have this data yet but we do have some
preliminary data that I'm going to show
you in a couple of seconds and I'd like
to take this opportunity to show you a
little bit of how you can analyze data
like that using the tools that the
thermo Fisher cloud has to offer so this
is a cloud space where you can upload
all your data and you can not only store
it there but you can also use some tools
on the site to analyze them and this is
done by creating a new project there's a
button that you can press for that and
you can then import data files for this
specific project and and in our case now
what we want to do with a relative
connotation study so you press the RQ
button and then you will be presented
with a couple of options of organizing
your data and then also analyzing your
data for the specific task so the first
thing is organizing your data telling
the system which ones of your samples
belong to what kind of bio group and in
our case again as you have already seen
now a couple of times is we have chronic
pancreatitis samples on the one hand and
doctor on the adenocarcinoma samples on
the other hand and once you've organized
your data you can take a look at what
did your plate setup look like it's all
of this correct and review your data and
the next step and you can do this either
target specific so look at what did your
individual markers or genes look like
across the different samples this is
what you see here but if you select a
different option
in a tab like this year for example you
can also do this plate wise or reaction
wise if you will so you can go through
your data and before you do any kind of
analysis to see how did they perform
from a pure technical standpoint and
then for the analysis itself there is a
couple of tools that the system provides
a very informative tool here of course
is again the hierarchical cluster
analysis but highlighted here as well
for example is an option to reduce box
plots to look at market expression
across bio groups or samples so a lot of
options that you can use and if you look
at the hierarchical clustering and that
the data of our 88 specific markers
produced what you can see here is that
this the the clustering clearly puts the
chronic pancreatitis samples separately
and apart from the ductal adenocarcinoma
samples so there seems to be clearly a
difference present in the markers that
you can find in serum from patients that
suffer from either inflammatory or
malignant tumors of the pancreas what
you also see is that the expression
patterns among the group of dr.
adenocarcinoma patients varies very
strongly and this is something that is
known there is a high variability in
expression patterns among individual
tumors and this is another reason why
looking at many markers simultaneously
is probably a way to get to better
diagnosis of this disease just as a very
quick outlook
one thing that we're also working on
together with the folks at thermo Fisher
is to try and include yet another level
of detection in the mixed segments array
so we'd also like to be able to look for
gene specific mutations so mutations
that are typical for ductal
adenocarcinoma tumors in the same
analysis steps also including these on
the mixed segment arrays and the
technology that could provide for this
is the cast PCR technology so alley
specific PCR that could be used to
detect specific mutations so if it if it
turns out to be possible to combine all
three levels of genomic analysis in one
segment area card we could not only look
for expression levels of mRNA and micro
RNA marker genes but at the same time
also detect presence or absence of
specific mutations which should further
improve the diagnostic accuracy of the
calls that we're doing so with that I'd
like to thank the large number of people
that have contributed to these studies
over the years very specifically I'd
like to thank Rita and Kathleen from
thermo Fisher in South San Francisco
whom we are working with very closely on
these projects and then also
collaborators from Germany all over
Europe the group in Marburg Tamas Kassai
gamma X Sen Bawa and last but definitely
not least the people in my group were
actually of course doing all the work
and with it I'd like to thank you for
your attention and I'm happy to take any
questions
Thank You dr. Birkins for that wonderful
presentation we are not ready for
questions and answers from the audience
please remember to enter your question
into the chat box on the lower left
corner and we will answer as many as
possible during the course of this
presentation the first question is from
Ivey our mrnas and micro rna's we in
blood or associated with extracellular
vesicle well we personally haven't
checked for that in our samples but if
you look in the literature both will be
true so there will be mRNAs and micro
rna's that are just associated to
proteins like argan out some more or
less really floating in in the
bloodstream but there are definitely
also microvesicles and extras ohms that
are circulating we assume that we're
catching both with the methods that we
use and so but we have no way of
discriminating or attaching percentages
how many of the markets that we see are
either free floating or exosome bound so
I my answer would be probably both
but we haven't discriminated between
them great another question from Irene
do we have the same technology for
castration resistant prostate cancer so
well in principle the technology would
work the same the selection of markers
would of course be different or would
probably be different for other types of
cancer and we have so far concentrated
on pancreatic cancer so I can't give any
indication of which marker combinations
would be sensible to test for prostate
cancer but in principle the technology
should work the same great we have a
question from Christy do you think the
next teknon arrays could be suitable for
screening the general population of
stage pancreatic cancer yes it would be
a very nice thing to do because of
course catching the tumor early would be
the ideal situation to to help the
patient as best we can the problem here
is with screening is that we're fighting
numbers the incidence of the tumor in
the general population is really low
which is of course a good thing because
otherwise we would see more deaths by
pancreatic cancer but on the other hand
the reason that or the the fact that
there are so few people who contract the
disease although they will probably all
die from the disease means that we would
have to screen a lot of people before we
find one who actually has a magnetic
tumor that has not been detected yet and
in the process we would invariably
produce many false positive codes so we
would be confronting patients or people
who don't really have cancer falsely
with the diagnosis of pancreatic cancer
and so this is on two hands on the one
hand from the economic side and on the
other hand from from the ethical side
not really feasible so we will have to
concentrate on high-risk groups like
tumor recurrence in patients that
already have the cancer great we have a
question for Emmanuel hisses thank you
for the presentation
do we have any experience profiling
fecal micro RNA as a delete biomarker if
so how the libel is fecal microarray in
pancreatic cancer biomarker no actually
we have not tried that we have briefly
worked with viewing with patient urine
and there is in principle we can detect
microRNAs in urine as well
but we have not followed that up in in
any greater study or any greater detail
we have not looked for fecal mRNA I know
that other groups are using protein
detection in fecal matter ella stays and
and other markers to try and distinguish
between inflammatory and malignant
processes in the pancreas but we haven't
looked for mRNA and microarray markers
in fecal samples great we have a
question from Debra how close do you
think a blood based assay is and which
technology company do you think is the
closest to commercializing a blood based
test okay so I can't really speak to
that with any kind of authority because
so we are an academic group in in the
hospital in University Hospital of
Marburg here so we are really coming
from a academic side definitely the
issue of commercialization is a whole
other beast and I have little experience
in this field and actually so I wouldn't
be qualified to answer who will be first
to market I think but I mean how close
our blood based assays there are already
some on the market so and in principle
detecting analytes in blood has been
used for four decades now of course
proteins of different kinds have been
detected and there are groups that are
also looking for combinations of
detecting mutations or genomic DNA from
circulating tumor cells as well as
protein markers so market detection in
blood is a
new this specific combination that we
are using here microRNAs and mrnas I'm
not aware that anybody is in the process
of commercializing something like that
but of course I can be wrong great we
had a question from Jorge is there any
genetic background that produces
pancreatic cancer yes there is well we
have to distinguish between on the one
hand sporadic pancreatic cancer where
there is no indication that there is a
genetic basis it's purely or presumably
purely arising from somatic mutations
that are acquired through life and on
the other hand there is a number of
families where there's clearly a
significant enlarged or a heightened
frequency of pancreatic cancer
occurrences and we call this familial
pancreatic cancer it's a syndrome that's
well described but in very few cases in
very few families have we actually
detected the causative mutations
probably in these families as well it's
probably a multi genetic occurrence
there are very few cases where we can
point to a mutation in bracket two
there's probably causative but in others
it would be a combination that's not so
easy to detect great we have a question
on the data analysis so how is the data
from the combined assays normalized it
seems like the normalization of these
data setting is a popular question
that's coming in right so we did or we
included let's call them housekeeping
genes separately for on the one end for
the mRNA essays and on the other hand
for the micro RNA essays so the mRNA
see T values that's the the raw data
that you get from these analyses these
were normalized separately to mRNA
reference genes and the micro RNA essays
the C key values that come from those
those are normalized to a small molecule
reference genes so in the first versions
of our mixed arrays these were small
nuclear rnas and in the the newer
version now we have included 5 micro
rna's that are reported to be very
stable expressed across all kinds of
different tissues and and body fluids
and our results indicate that these are
indeed very stable so that's what we're
using for normalization in this context
we are on the other hand we are also
constantly analyzing our own data and to
try and see is there any better way for
normalization or for work about the raw
data before we make diagnostic holes but
so far the classical normalization to
so-called housekeeping genes is what
works best in our hands great could you
speak to other scenarios in which
simultaneous detection of micro RNA mRNA
could be useful yes so I can think of
several actually the most I mean we are
working in the field of cancer and
cancer is the disease of that arises
from mutations that ultimately cause
differences in gene expression and we
know that micro RNAs are important
players in regulating expression of
other genes so of course if you have a
specific pathway specific set of mRNA
genes that you're interested in and you
have a number of micro RNAs that you
suspect of being involved in regulating
the specific set of mRNA genes
of course it would make sense to have
them combined on a microfluidic card to
be able to analyze them simultaneously
so if you think that there is a
coordinated change of expression of
microRNAs and the target mRNAs this
would be a nice case to use mixed tech
memories for example so you can just
have all your answers in one view and
I'm sure there are many other scenarios
where where it would be advantages to
have a view on microarrays and mRNA
simultaneously and all kinds of
combinations are possible with these
mixed arrays of course click one more
question and this is actually our last
question of the day the heat map showing
clustering of CP and PDAC shows very
little difference in expression patterns
is this significant enough to
distinguish between the two simple types
good question I would actually disagree
slightly so I would not say that there
is very little difference in expression
patterns what we do see is that there is
considerable variation in expression of
these individual markers in individual
patient samples and that's actually
something that we've learned along the
way and not only us but many people also
if you look at the recent publications
on large-scale genomic analysis in
pancreatic cancer there is a large
degree of inter - Miral heterogeneity
and and I'm not quite sure how to
quantify this but the authors of a
recent nature paper have actually
concluded that pancreatic cancer is the
tumor with the highest degree of
intramural heterogeneity so it's
expected that you get flexure
of expression of individual markers
across different samples from different
cancer patients and that's exactly why
we need but we probably will never find
a single marker or just a handful of
markers that will reliably distinguish
between pancreatic cancer and other
diseases for all the patients
it will probably always be a more
complicated set of signatures that we
can find in individual patients and
that's why we are working very closely
together with by informatics departments
to find those more complicated
expression patterns but our preliminary
data so far seem to indicate that we
will be quite capable of distinguishing
between tumor patients and controls the
question will be what diagnostic
accuracy can we really reach so how
accurate can we really become great we
have many more questions coming in but
maybe we'll stay take one last question
before we stop the heat map showing
clustering sorry um how can we
distinguish between exocrine and
endocrine tumor using this method so
it's a also a good question of course
for those participants who are not so
familiar with the field of cancer in the
pancreas so in in the pancreas you have
two types of cells the exocrine cells in
the endocrine cells and both can give
cancers the exocrine cancers are the bad
ones the endocrine cancers are much less
aggressive actually and they produce a
clearly different pattern of marker
expression compared to doctor
carcinoma so it's not a problem to
distinguish between endocrine and
exocrine tumors using these markers but
it's not a very pressing diagnostic need
at the moment anyway because endocrine
tumors can be diagnosed very well
already with the methods that are
already in the clinic but when we do get
the the odd endocrine cancer sample in
our analyses we can always clearly see
that they're different from the ductal
adenocarcinoma so great thank you so
much doctor because this was a very
informative presentation and many thanks
to the audience for the engagement for
those questions that we didn't get to
during the course of this webinar we
will certainly respond back to you
privately I would also like to thank lab
Rhodes for making today's webcast
possible this for me no I wanted to let
everyone know that today's webinar will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 2018 you will receive an
email from lab notes letting you know
wendish webinars available for replay
please share this announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon bye bye and have a great rest
of the day